Speaker 1: We have a voicemail number.
That number is 2192. David P You know,
one thing I've learned in doing this
show, homophobic people don't like
being called homophobic. Take a listen to this.
Speaker 5: Hi, David. I'm calling from Decatur,
Georgia. You know, I watch your show regularly.
And any time someone doesn't agree with the
homosexual, lesbian, transgender lifestyle, you
call them transphobic or homophobic. Hmm. And I
think that's wrong. People have a right to their
own beliefs. And I think you should stop labeling
people as having a phobia because they disagree
with their lifestyle. You should probably check
yourself out on that. Mm hmm. Thank you.
Speaker 1: Listen, the mere use of the word
lifestyle is already problematic. Homophobes
that I've been interviewing for more than a
decade. Love to talk about the gay lifestyle,
and that is a flag that you are homophobic. Now,
I think it's important to understand that when
we use the term homophobic and transphobic,
a lot of people like to play the kind of literal
semantic games where they go, It's not a phobia.
I just think it's wrong. This is similar to when
people when they hear the phrase anti-Semitism,
they go, Why is the word anti-Semitism?
Semites also include people of Arab descent,
not just Jews. Right. But Google. The term
anti-Semitism. The term anti-Semitism,
even though the etymology relates to Semite, is
related specifically to anti-Jewish sentiment.
And similarly, when we talk about homophobia and
transphobia, we don't literally mean I'm afraid
it's a phobia. It is more all encompassing than
that. So not a shock. Homophobes and Transphobes
don't like to be called that. We're going to
have a fantastic bonus show today. We'll talk
about the collapse. We will talk about lab grown
meat being cleared for human consumption. And
we will talk about over a billion young people
being at risk for hearing loss. Something that
I have much to say about. Sign up. Join
Pacman dot com. Don't miss today's fun.